honey this look in the film cheetah
barbara what did you do kristen i love
seeing you in this type of character and
the evolution of it
the film has you doing things that we've
never seen kristen wiig do before you
are running it like
super sonic speeds you are fighting you
were doing acrobatics
and honey this look in the film
cheetah i tell you the final look of her
uh for you know that the final form of
cheetah it is just
out of this world but what did that
transformation take how long was that
process
oh you mean to get into the final look
kind of look yeah it was
uh a lot
it was a lot of um yeah prosthetics
um teeth wigs hair
um hair going down the back of the neck
um yeah it was a lot but it was i mean
it was so fun it was like such a dream
of mine to
do anything like this so it was like
i loved every minute of it at the end of
the day though like when you have to
shoot
so many showdown scenes like you did in
the film
how do you recuperate from something
like that how do you wind down
um epsom salt baths
multiple times a day creams
with menthol no i mean it was it was
um it was intense yeah um
because when you're not shooting your
your training or you're working with
stunting or
memorizing choreography and doing all
that stuff so
you show up to shoot and you're already
tired and sore
um but i mean once you're there
and like you see
all the people working so hard and the
sets
and like yeah all in her outfit like the
first time i saw her
in her wonder woman outfit i was like
because i was such a fan of the
first one and i'm like i love superhero
movies
and i got a little geeked out and i mean
the whole experience you're just sort of
like
what is going on and the fact that i got
to do this fight season train and
do that stuff with her it was like it
was a dream come true
you've always had everything while
people like me have had nothing
well now it's my turn
get used to it and you guys have
achieved quite a friendship out of all
of this as well you know we got some
super sneak peek behind the scenes
footage of y'all clowning around joking
singing songs in between takes and then
you'd be like
okay now it's time for me to fight you
but i just love the friendship that's
blossomed from it all as well
me too she's one of the
warmest kindest like she has such a big
heart i mean you can
tell you can tell when you see people on
the screen
she's just not even because she's wonder
woman but she just radiates that
kindness in all aspects of her life and
i feel
really lucky that she's my friend well
honey she has the same sentiment about
you that is for sure
she said the same so you know it's so
cool in this film we see
you know diana's got the cool girl
persona then barbara like i said she's
got like this
nerdy geek sheet kind of vibe going on i
don't know about the chic
i was trying to be kind to barbs okay
growing up who did you align more with
and did that kind of mentality that you
had as a kid to
impact you later in life and persuade
you into
what you're doing now kind of like it
did barbara
oh that's a good question um you're
welcome
i i was definitely uh
sort of a mix i mean it's kind of not
that different than
how i am now i feel like i can be very
introverted and
um socially awkward um but at the same
time i
for a living i do perform so
it's it is kind of like a combination of
of the two of them um i definitely
relate
more to barbara in the beginning
um but you know there is something about
um diana's character that
is so heartbreaking in this movie
because she's so lonely and
and her reasons for not being able to
connect with people are it's just like
so heartbreaking um so i don't know i
feel like people can
see themselves in in both of them and
they have this attraction to each other
because they're similar but on the
outside they're they're complete
opposites which i think is such a
cool thing that the script um
you'll included all that you dream of
and want
and everything will be different another
one that really
resonated with me was when the amazons
told young diana
like just wait for your time you know
and i love that wisdom that they
imparted upon her but what is maybe some
wisdom that you're hoping to
pass down to now your children since you
are a new mama now
gosh there's so much especially right
now
um in this like really weird
time that we're in i think we've all
like gone inward a lot
and realized things that we not only
like hold really dear but things that we
want to change and like
teach our kids and especially now
what's going on politically and just
in the world being like kind to each
other
just goes such a long way
and can spread um and so
i don't know that that's a big thing i
want to teach my kids is
you know we're all in this life together
and just
to be to show love to each other
i love that and we do need to i'm like
kristen how has motherhood changed your
perception of life
i just love seeing you in this day i
mean
it's the best everyone i know everyone
always says that but um
it and everyone says like it changes how
you look at the world and how you like
um see love like now it's just like such
a bigger thing and all of that stuff is
is so true but especially being in this
business
um you're you're on your own a lot and
you make your own decisions
and you're you're it can be very sort of
like
an like an isolated existence
and now that i have kids it's like oh i
don't want this to be about me i don't
want to think about me anymore
um and just having these like two other
little beings that i get to take care of
is like so
amazing and um
but it's also even though it's hard i'm
i feel more relaxed in a way really yeah
i mean right now because they're in
there it's not here
you're like maybe never in a second but
i'm
i'm so excited like i had this sense of
like calm after they were
born i love that and we are so happy for
you
and that's a beautiful thing and i hope
honey we see cheetah back for more with
wonder woman is she going to be back
hope so patty pickens are you watching i
that would be so fun i hope so we hope
so too
and other dc films just saying